JAMES STEWARD: Princeton
began building a campus art
collection decades ago.
As both a manifestation of
its commitment to modern art--
this came about largely
through the so-called Putnam
Collection, that was
committed to collecting works
by the so-called
modern masters--
and as a way of putting art
in the path of everyday life
all across campus.
And seeing it as a way of
enriching the campus experience
writ large.
We already have in the
Putnam Collection, one work
by Alexander Calder.
And this gives us an
opportunity, and a way,
to think of this as a
campus-wide exhibition
of highlights of
Calder's output.
Right now, in front
of the museum,
we have two Calders
on loan to us
from the Fisher
Family Collection.
What I think is
especially arresting
about Calder's production,
is that he worked primarily
in two idioms.
He's the inventor of what were
called the mobiles and then
the so-called stabiles.
In both cases they're
important for the fact
that he was one of
the real innovators
in the move towards
pure abstraction.
Leaving aside any
notion of representation
in the form of the sculpture.
I think in the case of both Man,
and The Kite That Never Flew,
it's tempting to see them
in their relationship
to each other in a somewhat
anthropomorphic way.
Almost at times make me think
of ancient animals stalking
one another across the Plaza
in front of the museum,
because of the way he uses
the folded metal form.
They are both purely abstract
and yet resonant of something
that is almost kind of
subconscious or subliminal.
Abstract art can
liberate us in a sense
because we can bring our own
thoughts and issues to it.
It doesn't overtly tell us
a clear narrative in the way
that representational
art would be.
That's of course exactly what
some people find so difficult
about abstraction.
Because they are
curious, they're
troubled by the lack of
clarity about meaning.
That is I think,
it's very power.
And my message to visitors
would be to feel empowered.
To let their minds run.
To say, what might this mean?
How can I develop a relationship
with this sculpture?
I think one of the
great values of having
that sculpture in the
landscape, for a time,
is that one can have repeat
experiences of it, including
accidental ones.
When you simply are
walking past the Museum
along the [INAUDIBLE]
walk and discover these
under different light conditions
and different weather.
To experience them when
it was actively snowing,
was a wholly different
experience of those sculptures.
When someone put it
to me, they appeared
to be dancing in
the falling snow
and it was remarkably true.
They were animated
in a different way
than they would be on
a bright sunny day.
And I think that's
again a part of where
the richness of experience of
abstract art can come from.